[Musique]
la thérapie génique obtient de plus en
plus de succès un exemple un nouveau
médicament qui permet de soigner un
jeune enfant souffre d'une rare maladie
neurologique ce traitement le plus cher
du monde sera couvert par québec voici
comment la décision a été prise
[Musique]
audrey et frédéric qui sont les parents
de jacob 18 mois leur garçon est atteint
d'une maladie rare
l'agneau trophy musculaire spinale en
ontario la maladie est dépistée dès la
naissance né au québec ce n'est pas le
cas
si jacob itani en ontario on l'aurait su
puis on aurait pu faire des procédures
avant de key qui a eu une dégénérescence
qui sortent dans son corps la maladie de
jacob est le résultat de mutation au
niveau du gène
snlc un gène qui est très important pour
la survie et la fonction des neurones
moteurs de la moelle épinière
qu'on ne pas se joindre qui fonctionne
correctement on a une perte progressive
de ces neurones moteurs qui va entraîner
une faiblesse progresser au fil des mois
les muscles de jacob s'atrophie son
corps perd son tonus plus tard il
pourrait avoir des difficultés à avaler
et à respirer
pour freiner la progression de la
maladie jacob reçoit le spin rasa le
médicament s'administre à la manière
d'une ponction lombaire c'est à dire
qu'on insère une aiguille entre deux
vertèbres
le médicament est donné trois fois par
an et ce pour le reste de la vie des
moments pénibles la première injection
rappelle de bien mauvais souvenirs
une grosse journée
c'était dans la colonne
heureusement à l'automne 2021 jacob
recevra un nouveau traitement lol
genzyme a c'est le médicament le plus
cher du monde il coûte 2,8 millions de
dollars la dose et québec en assumer les
coûts d'utilisation
[Musique]
jusqu'à tours et ferment les traitements
qu'on avait
ralenti la progression de ces maladies
dégénératives
produit par la société pharmaceutique
novartis le seul jendouba est une
thérapie génique par voie directe
c'est-à-dire qu'elle corrigera la
maladie en livrant un gène dans les
cellules
on ne fait pas juste ralentir la
progression de maladies mortelles mais
vraiment faire des gains moteur qu'on
n'aurait jamais autrement et quand on
arrive à traiter à ses taux avant le
début des symptômes leur donner une vie
quasi normale
pour livrer le gène le médicament
utilise un virus ce dernier ne rend pas
malade il n'a pas la capacité de se
reproduire mais il a le pouvoir de
traverser la barrière qui protège le
cerveau une fois cette barrière franchie
le médicament permet de préserver les
neurones moteurs de la moelle épinière
même si la thérapie génique et coûteuse
elle est appelée à se répandre dans ce
contexte comment québec prend t-il la
décision de rembourser ou non un nouveau
médicament pour comprendre le cas du
zèle jen sma il faut remonter au
printemps 2020
[Musique]
ottawa 21 mai 2020 novartis présentent
une demande à santé canada la société
aimerait que son médicament le lodge and
may soit autorisée est commercialisé au
pays
le document contient de nombreux
fichiers dont le résultat d'études
cliniques sur cette base les experts de
santé canada évalueront son innocuité et
son efficacité
26 juin 2020 parallèlement à sa démarche
auprès de santé canada novartis
présentent une demande au québec
l'institut national d'excellence en
santé et en services sociaux inesss
étudiera le dossier c'est lui qui
recommande au ministère de la santé
qu'un médicament soit ou non remboursés
par le régime public
[Musique]
novembre 2020 le comité d'experts de
l'inesss se réunit pandémie oblige la
discussion se déroule par
visioconférence le comité se compose
d'une quinzaine de scientifiques à
l'exception de deux personnes qui
représentent le public les
considérations sont nombreuses le débat
tourne principalement autour de la
valeur thérapeutique du médicament et de
ses effets sur la qualité de vie on doit
aussi établir les conditions pour
lesquelles le médicament pourrait être
remboursée
décembre 2020 santé canada rend publique
sa décision le hall genzyme a sera
commercialisé sous le numéro
d'identification
02 50 96 95 à québec les experts de
l'inesss se rencontrent à nouveau
après des heures de discussions le
comité à ce vote un vote secret à
l'unanimité ils recommandent qu'on
rembourse le médicament leur décision ne
surprend personne
[Musique]
c'est tellement efficace que ça ça sauf
quand même au système beaucoup en termes
d'hospitalisation de soins est également
à chaque fois qu'on venait pour des
procédures qui doivent se répéter ou
quatre mois c'est un club beaucoup de
médecins beaucoup professionnel de la
santé si un coup au système qu'il faut
prendre en compte également aussi donc
je ne sais pas faire macroéconomistes
mais je pense que ça a pesé dans la
balance mais je pense quand même que le
point principal c'était une efficacité
la recommandation de l'inesss tient sur
46 pages avant d'être rendu public on la
transmet à christian dubé ministre de la
santé c'est lui qui aura le dernier mot
mais dans les faits le ministre ne fait
qu'appliquer la recommandation de
l'inesss
15 octobre 2021 dix mois après avoir
reçu la recommandation guinness le
ministre rend publique sa décision les
halls jendouba sera couvert par le
régime et ce dès la semaine suivante
chaque année six à huit enfants
pourraient en bénéficier
quel bugs quelle belle nouvelle ça fait
des années que ça aurait dû être réglée
sur les régler maintenant il faut
lorsqu'on parle de la vie des gens on
l'a vu le des enjeux qu'on ne lui a pas
mis à mon avis a jamais de prix pour la
vie des gens alors je vous dis moi
j'avais des frissons cette semaine quand
on ne réussit à faire passer l'entente
avec novartis puis de savoir que le but
en forme et est moins difficile je pense
pas que personne qui boit questionner
les coups qu'on met là dedans parce que
c'était la bonne chose à part ces femmes
il
a été vraiment un gros soulagement de
savoir qui c'était en bout c'est
[Musique]
un gros soulagement
y allait peut-être pu avoir
d'intervention sauf l'injection
chu sainte-justine 24 novembre 2021
8h40 c'est le grand jour une première
pour tous on pose une voix d'henneuse à
jacob pour lui administrer le médicament
9h08 ensuite tels que le protocole exige
la docteur nguyên doit autoriser la
préparation du médicament
à la pharmacie on s'active le médicament
ne peut rester à température ambiante
rien n'est laissé au hasard une douzaine
de rencontres préparatoires ont été
nécessaires pour prévoir la séquence des
événements de la réception du médicament
jusqu'à la perfusion de jacob
10h15 jacob reçoit enfin le dow jones
m'a donné par perfusion au
l'administrent en une seule dose
fini les ponctions lombaires il reste
encore une inconnue les données
cliniques du médicament porte sur les
enfants de moins de 6 mois jacob à
presque 19 mois dans les p tits chez les
très jeunes enfants les résultats sont
tellement spectaculaire qu'on s'attend
quand même à des bons résultats chez les
enfants plus vieux mais en même temps
avec des effets secondaires plus
significatif parce que les études ont
montré que les effets secondaires sont
proportionnelles au poids de l'enfant
qui vient surproportionnelle alors
mon effort vis-à-vis médicaments c'est
sûr que je veux voir jacob progresser au
maximum sinon plus le mrap et le voir
peut-être dans le meilleur des mondes de
faire quelques pas ça serait parfait
pour moi
la rebelle réalisa
quelques jours avant le traitement de
jacob l'inesss a recommandé au ministère
de la santé d'ajouter l'amyotrophie
musculaire spinale à la liste des
maladies des pistes et à la naissance
québec devrait suivre sa recommandation
rappelons que l'efficacité de cette
thérapie génique est maximale
lorsqu'elle est donnée avant
l'apparition des premiers symptômes
dans l'école les enfants traités avec le
jeune james may avant le début des
symptômes généralement donc on appelle
ça près symptomatique généralement avant
six semaines de vie on voit qu'ils ont
un développement moteur quasi normal
même normal et un taux de survie de 100%